transacting vision into Africa I think
from CNBC africa where we report on
economic needs across sub-saharan Africa
everybody I think translating vision
into action is going to come from
leadership without a doubt only
leadership is going to make it happen
and I think we're seeing a new breed of
leader in the business and government
environment across sub-saharan Africa
where there is a collective there's also
a collective responsibility and no long
which is to regional Victoria interests
I think sub-saharan Africa starting to
see itself as the economic bloc that is
I think sub-saharan Africa scene itself
as the mass market or 715 million
consumers that can change from within
and I think within that the World
Economic Forum certainly explain each
other helping to change perceptions
about effort to end by changing
perceptions will help turning just
simple visions into action in Africa